Speaker 1: Welcome to The David Pakman Show,
I am David Pakman if he dyed his hair red
and got stung by a thousand bees, I am jessee
dollar more.
Thanks for joining me today.
Again, I want to thank David for asking me
to talk to co-host, but substitute this week.
It's I'm flattered.
I'm honored.
And I would appreciate it if you would follow
me on social media.
I'm at Darla Moore just about everywhere from
YouTube, Twitter, Tic-Tac.
I'm all over the place just at dolma.
Today, I want to talk about a friend of the
program, Mike Lyndell, or as David would call
him, Mike Pelo, the cyber symposium that has
been talked about for seemingly ever started
today.
And it was postponed because of who he was
hacked, according to Mike Lyndell, which obviously
cannot be trusted because he is a grifter
and a charlatan and a liar.
I'm going to read from this article in The
Independent briefly and then I'll play a couple
of clips from the madness that ensued today.
Mike Pillow excuse me, my pillow CEO, Michael
Andell DeLay, start of cyber symposium claiming
he has been hacked.
Conspiracy theorist claims there was more
evidence of election malfeasance in November
and December than any crime in history.
That's saying a lot, considering the the crimes
that we have witnessed throughout history,
that Donald Trump losing an election was the
biggest.
It says a lot about not just where the right
is right now, but also where Mike Lyndell
is.
And before I go on, I want to admonish everybody
that, listen, I'm a guy I don't mind a few
insults.
I don't mind flinging a few names here and
there.
But to impugn this man because he is a former
drug addict, I think is misguided.
I don't need to come to Mike's defense like
Mike, like we're friends.
But addiction is a disease.
Addiction isn't a moral failure.
And if you're going to pick on somebody for
something, that shouldn't be it.
There's plenty of ammunition to use against
Mike Lyndell that doesn't involve his struggles
with addiction.
Having said that, I want to read a little
bit from this article.
My pillow CEO and pro Trump conspiracy theorist
Mike Lyndell delayed the start of his, quote,
unquote, cyber symposium after claiming that
the whole technology was attacked.
I guess I could do the the mike lyndell voice
for the quotes.
The whole technology was attacked.
Ya couldn't.
He is like a character from the movie Fargo.
We need to get the word out because they blocked
the thing.
Technologist futurists understand of modernity
and technology.
They blocked the thing.
But this is part of what I'm going to talk
about today.
This is a cover up.
This is the absolute cover up of the worst
in history, Mr. Lyndell today told a crowd
in South Dakota on Tuesday.
The audience had gathered to hear evidence
of the baseless conspiracy theory that the
twenty twenty election was stolen from former
President Donald Trump.
Mr. Lyndell claimed that his symposium will
show that China hacked the election to make
sure that Joe Biden won.
There's no evidence of this.
And election security experts have said that
the twenty twenty election was one of the
safest in U.S. history.
Now, I will remind you, I'm sure you remember
that in November, Donald Trump's own Department
of Homeland Security declared this election
the safest and most secure in the history
of the country.
That's saying something, but still, these
conspiracy ding dongs are running across the
country hosting cyber symposiums with their
fake nonsense, they're streaming data of just
merely metadata and attempting to continue
to whip the right into a frenzy, into a conspiratorial
rage that we already witnessed violence at
the hands of.
These people who believe Donald Trump last
are the same people who stormed the capital.
Harming over one hundred and fifty police
officers.
The same people, so this isn't just a fanciful
thing of some wingnut out there in South Dakota.
There are real world ramifications to this
real harm can be done, real lives can be ruined.
Here's a couple of video clips.
The first is when he's announcing the postponement,
the short postponement because of the dreaded
hack.
Speaker 2: But we do have a backup plan.
It'll still be probably another five minutes.
And I want all of you guys are all you guys
to know that out there, that this is why?
Because I need to get the word out.
We can't even get the word out to the people
that are prank speech dotcom because they
blocked the thing or blocked the thing.
But this is part of what I'm going to talk
about today, this is the cover up, this is
the absolute cover up of this of the worst
crime in history.
And we're going to talk about all this today.
It says, and you're going to see all kinds
of things.
We're going to educate everybody.
We're going to show them that they are we're
going to be running.
I'll show you over here to see this data that's
run in there at cyber data from the from what
I've got.
But see if it's moving.
You know, it's not it's not rotating yet,
but there's going an endless stream for days
and we put six states up there.
But I just we're not going to start the regular
program, though, because I want to start because
it's all education.
It all goes in sequence.
I will say this.
Everybody, tonight you're going to see something
at seven o'clock.
That it's going to change the world and and
then also tomorrow.
You're going to hear
Speaker 1: that applause seems a little tepid
for the announcement to come on the heels
of the announcement that it's going to change
the world, we go to change change world.
I'll give you a little clip.
The other part I want to share with you is
and I'm laughing, by the way, because it is
hilarious.
This man is a funny person.
He is objectively goofy.
Someone came to him and said that we're going
to go to lunch and he refused.
In fact, he he got aggressive about it and
I'm not taking too long.
I'm going to live stream.
Just bizarre,
Speaker 2: they attacked me, they buried it.
You think about that.
But they got something they want to show you
off stage.
OK, I guess we have something off stage.
So we're live streaming, though.
So you want to talk?
I think we're going to I think we're set up
for a break and maybe we're going to talk
a little bit.
Right.
When we get back there, we're going to go
in.
We're not going on a break.
Put up that movie again.
Run the movie.
There's no breaks.
We're streaming 72 hours live streaming.
So around the world, this never stops.
You guys can go eat.
That's fine.
But I ain't eating.
I'm staying up here for 72 hours before they
ruin our signal with the movie.
Ladies and gentlemen, lunch is now available
in the back hallway.
Thank you.
We're going to put the movie up again, if
everybody you should, I want to go to the
movie up tabulation system and then we'll
come back from the movie and we're going to
have Dr. Frank.
He's going to get down there and do his presentation.
So is the movie going came together?
Because there is the movie I've heard about
this morning with this movie.
Speaker 1: So no lunch for Lyndell.
He's too focused on the task at hand to uncover
the world changing data at his cyber symposium,
which, by the way, is being live streamed
by like Steve Bannon on Real America's Voice,
you know, not fake America's voice, real America's
voice